Film Courage: Going back to the question ‘How
Does the Film and Television Industry Work?’
Let’s suppose someone has a reputable agent.
This writer has checked them out and they
know that they’re in good standing, there’s
no grievances or complaints.
And then they’ve had this agent submit on
behalf of them to a studio, what’s the process
like?
What should they expect?
What’s the timeframe?
What if the work is optioned?
What happens?
Kathie Fong Yoneda: That’s a lot of questions
at one time.
Certainly it does take time, there are more
than a 1,000 pieces of material submitted
every month to the studios.
Maybe slightly less to larger production companies,
but that is a lot of material.
Somebody has got to read it.
It’s got to go up a chain of command so
it does take a little while.
I would say reasonable time, they usually
get things done, read it and will be able
to tell you in 4 to 6 weeks roughly.
That’s what it used to be when I was working
at the studios.
It could be slightly longer now, although
a lot of times, now everything is on computer
so you can just read it at your leisure.
You don’t have to wait for things to be
mailed and that kind of stuff.
But I do think that a lot of times it also
depends on who else is submitting material.
There may be a more important agent or there
may be an agent that has a script that has
some famous actor or director attached to
it.
They are going to get preference.
So sometimes scripts get pushed down a little
lower, a little lower, a little lower so you
do have to watch out for that.
I do think it’s important that people understand
that for first-timers, you’re going to be
there up toward the bottom.
So it probably would be longer, four to six
weeks.
And if you don’t hear anything, what you
do is you just email or call your agent and
just ask them about it.
Also find out from them if they’ve heard
anything because usually they don't just submit
it to one place.
They usually try to submit it to a few places
because they want to get a consensus of what
(in general) the producers and the studio
people are looking for.
Film Courage: Well let’s suppose somebody
says “We like it.
It’s a go!”
What happens?
What are some of the possibilities?
Kathie Fong Yoneda: Well first of all, I don’t
think they are going to say it right away!
[Laughs] But they will probably say “We
are interested in this, can you tell us more?”
And one of the other questions they are going
to ask…
“What else do you have?”
Because they want to know (if they like your
writing) what else do you have?
What genre is it?
Is this somebody that…a writer that we want
to get a jump on their other material?
They are always thinking ahead because they
don’t want to just put all their eggs in
one basket.
They want to know that there is somebody that’s
got free-flowing talent that’s going to
continue to build a relationship on.
And that’s why agents are always going to
ask that of you before they take you on as
a client.
Film Courage: “What else do you have?”
Kathie Fong Yoneda: “What else to you have?”
that…and because the studio and the producers
always ask “What else does this guy have?”
they want to know does this writer have more
material because they would like to look at
more material.